after covering three thousand six
hundred kilometers with a completely
electric powered motorbike green energy
lobbyists urine eliz and Frank Edna
arrived in Marrakech an advertisement
for environmentally friendly travel two
weeks ago in Berlin the world looked
much different but since then Donald
Trump was elected the next president of
the United States a twist that
dramatically affected conference
preparations Germany's Environment
Minister bah bahah Hendrix came to greet
the brave motorcyclists and she
highlighted the need to stand united
Melissa one shouldn't be misled by the
developments in the US which were
impossible for us to foresee the
important players are holding fast
that's China Europe Brazil and we will
stand together today those countries
most affected by climate change are
making statements they want to get away
from coal as quickly as possible a
challenge to Donald Trump his claim that
climate change is a hoax appears to be
giving added momentum to the conference
from one foot four or five of the
poorest nations are taking on energy
transition themselves they're no longer
waiting for the industrialized nations
to get up to speed the conference's main
message UN member states are committed
to staying the path of climate control
even without the US